el secretario de estado de los Estados
Unidos Anthony blinken lidera la primera
sesión plenaria de la quincuagésima
segunda asamblea de la organización de
los Estados Americanos que se reúne en
Perú hasta el 7 de octubre el primer eje
de debate se centra en la declaración de
los ángeles para que los países de
América Latina marquen las pautas en la
migración y protección la estrategia de
Anthony blinken es convencer a los
cancilleres de la importancia de
construir una agenda migratoria común en
la que se establezcan vías legales
protección a las personas así como una
activa lucha contra la trata y el
tráfico de personas el tema de esta
asamblea de la oea es juntos contra la
desigualdad y la discriminación es en
ese sentido que Honduras le pedirá
blinken una extensión del estatus de
protección temporal para atender a la
crisis migratoria paralelamente a esta
Cumbre el secretario de estado de los
Estados Unidos Anthony blinken se
reunirá a las 17 horas Lima Bogotá con
el presidente Pedro Castillo para borrar
asuntos de seguridad regional
fortalecimiento de la democracia y la
promoción a un desarrollo económico e
incluyente esta cumbre de la oea que se
realiza en Perú pasa desapercibida por
la población precisamente cuando las
autoridades de esta nación esperan que
la cita también les permita buscar una
solución a la inestabilidad política